It's rare for the SCP Foundation to encounter
an anomaly that volunteers information about
itself, that seems to actively desire to be
studied, to be investigated, to be known.
But SCP-082 is one such anomaly.
SCP-082 calls himself Fernand, a giant man
with an even bigger appetite, and though he
is cheerful and chatty, even friendly by SCP
Foundation standards, it can be difficult
to sort the fact from the fiction where his
life story is concerned.
At various points in his containment, he has
claimed to be a vampire, a homunculus, Sherlock
Holmes, Alexander the Great, Dr. Frankenstein
and his Monster, Napoleon, and Big Bird, to
name a few.
But on October 27, 2016, Fernand made a particular,
unusual request.
He asked for a set of poetry books, a stack
of blank paper, and a quill.
He isolated himself for days, refusing to
eat, drink, or sleep as he wrote page after
page.
When he was finished, he had written a poem
that seemed to be the first honest exploration
of his life story since he was first contained
by the Foundation.
It can be difficult to determine when SCP-082
is lying, since he is always grinning widely
and claims to only lie when it is "through
his teeth," but after reading the aforementioned
poem aloud, he wept openly in what seemed
to be a genuine display of emotion.
According to the events described in the poem,
which should still be taken with a small grain
of salt, this is what Fernand's life was like
before he became SCP-082.
Fernand could not remember his earliest years,
what his parents or his childhood home might
have looked like.
His earliest memory was of a makeshift home
in an alleyway, a box to sleep in, and a bundle
of rags serving as a makeshift bed.
For food, he would steal day-old bread thrown
out by a nearby bakery, and catch birds and
rats that were slow enough for him to grab.
Even as a young boy, he was enormous, three
times the size of other boys his age.
His strength and stature made him appealing
to the workhouses at first, but they always
ended up throwing him out, calling him a monster,
le monstre.
After the third workhouse chased him into
the streets with whips, he resigned himself
to a solitary life in the shadows, down the
abandoned alleyways where not even the beggars
would go, so overrun were they were rats and
filth.
It was better for Fernand that way, no one
would try to mock him, to hurt him, to dispose
of the monster once and for all.
He spent his days and nights there, in the
little alleyway he had turned into a home,
keeping as quiet as possible out of fear that
he would be discovered by someone with ill
intentions.
One night, he got his hands on a row of meat
tarts left on a windowsill and ate to his
heart's content.
He slept unusually soundly that night, with
a full belly for the first time in a long
time, and without knowing it, he must have
begun to snore.
As the first soft beams of sunlight fell across
his face, stirring him from sleep, he heard
the sound of a strange man's voice.
Perhaps it was someone just passing by on
a nearby street?
But no, there was a shadow at the end of the
alleyway, blocking out some of the light.
He retreated out of sight, hoping to avoid
detection, but he could see two more blurry
figures stepping into his vision.
All of a sudden, they started running toward
him at top speed.
This was no accidental encounter, they had
spotted him and were targeting him specifically.
For what?
He didn't want to find out.
The giant boy climbed to his feet and tried
to run, but the alley was narrow, and the
three men grabbed hold of each of his arms,
while one grabbed his legs and forced him
to the ground.
Someone stuffed a dirty rag into his mouth,
muffling his cries for help, and out of the
corner of his eye, he saw the glint of a metal
pipe swinging at his head.
Then, everything went dark.
When Fernand opened his eyes again, all he
could see at first was red, vivid red on all
sides.
As his vision adjusted, he realized he could
see metal bars as well.
The red was fabric, bright cloth draped over
the iron cage that now held him prisoner.
He stumbled to his feet, forced to stoop to
avoid bumping his head on the top of the cage,
and rattled the bars desperately.
"Let me out!
Please!"
He begged, though he felt as though it was
useless.
His plea was not met with silence, however,
but with loud, cheerful music.
He covered his ears at the sudden noise, jumping
back, but it came from all sides, and there
was no escape.
Suddenly, his eyes were blinded by a sudden
bright light as the red cloth was yanked from
the cage in one swoop.
It took a moment for his eyes to adjust, but
as he blinked the tears from his eyes, Fernand
could make out a man with a large mustache,
a long red and gold coat, a matching top hat,
and a gold-tipped cane.
The man grinned at him, but it was not a friendly
face.
The smile did not reach his eyes, which glinted
with a cold, cruel delight.
Behind the ringmaster, Fernand could now see
a crowd sitting: men, women, and children
all watching him with rapturous fascination,
a mix of intrigue, disgust, and horror on
their faces.
He looked from face to face, seeking any kindness,
any sympathy, but found not one who looked
as if they might help him escape.
The music climbed to a crescendo, and when
it stopped, the ringmaster spoke.
"Ladies and gentlemen, boys and girls, today
I have brought you something the likes of
which no one has ever seen before!
I have traveled the world in search of oddities
and curiosities to delight and shock you with,
and after crossing every ocean, exploring
the furthest reaches of the globe, I have
brought you a very special gift!
Do not be afraid, the beast will not harm
you!
I will ensure that you are all perfectly safe.
Should he try anything at all, one of my helpers
here," he gestured to one of two large men
standing on either side of the cage, each
brandishing an ax, "Will simply strike him
with their axes!"
Fernand recoiled at the threat, but there
was nowhere for him to go in the cramped cage,
already a bit too small for his massive body.
The ringmaster continued his speech, pacing
back and forth in front of the cage and running
his cane across the bars with a horrible clattering
sound.
"As you can see, this creature looks like
a boy, but his statue reveals the truth: it
is something else entirely!
Something bigger, stronger, more vicious than
any child could ever be!
You see the legs like great tree trunks, the
arms strong enough to wrestle a bear!
But do not, dear audience, neglect to notice
its mighty jaws!
Like steel, strong enough to crush anything
it bites down on, strong enough to crack through
bone!
And the teeth...enormous and pearly white,
with a smile bright enough to light up the
darkness.
What do you say, beast, will you give the
people a smile?"
Fernand cowered in the cage, watching everything
with wide, frightened eyes.
He certainly did not feel like smiling.
When he did not budge, the ringmaster thwacked
his cane against the bars, making another
horrible metallic clang.
"Well?
These people paid good money to be here, do
not keep them waiting!"
After another moment of silence and Fernand
remaining stock still, the audience began
to boo, tossing empty popcorn bags and insults
at the cage.
The ringmaster leaned in close and whispered,
"Smile for the people, or I'll see to it you
suffer agony you could only dream of."
This threat snapped Fernand out of his frozen
terror, and, standing as tall as he could
in the little cage, he smiled wide, showing
all of his many, many teeth at once.
The audience erupted into cheers at the sight,
and the band played triumphant horns as the
ringmaster basked in the applause.
"How about that?"
The ringmaster took off his hat and bowed
low to the ground, holding out the hat for
the audience to toss in coins in a token of
their appreciation for an excellent show.
By the time the applause was finished, his
hat was filled with shiny silver and gold.
He tossed the hat, now heavy with new wealth,
to one of the guards, and pulled a gold-handled
whip from his pocket.
"Ah, but I haven't finished yet!"
He cracked the whip ominously, then turned
toward the cage.
He cracked the whip again, this time across
Fernand's back.
The boy roared in pain, a great bellowing
sound that carried for miles around, and fell
to his knees.
The sound was so loud, so powerful, that the
audience was terrified.
Small children began to cry, and people poured
from the circus tent in a panic, afraid the
beast would break free and tear them apart.
But there was no beast, only a frightened
boy who did not understand his own strength,
crying at the cruelty the world had shown
him all his life.
Once they were alone, the ringmaster turned
to Fernand again, catching his eye.
"Stop your crying, boy.
From here on out, you will be coming with
me.
Together, we're going to be very, very rich.
And I will make you a star.
Whether you want to be one or not."
And for a time, that became Fernand's life.
Night after night, crammed into a cage, fed
on chicken bones and leftover scraps, paraded
in front of uncaring audiences as the ringmaster
tormented him, showed him off as a sideshow
attraction, and forced him to smile with the
threat of the ax or the whip.
His fellow circus folk were not much kinder
than the ringmaster, either.
The clowns sprayed him with water and taunted
him through the bars.
The animal trainers threatened to pit him
against their lions and see who came out alive.
Only one person ever showed Fernand an ounce
of kindness at the circus, a bearded lady
who would sing opera songs in a beautiful,
clear soprano.
Her voice was the loveliest thing Fernand
had ever heard, a tiny slice of heaven in
the hell his life had become.
Days bled together as the tour went on, a
stretch of seemingly endless days and nights,
until the day of the last show came.
He looked up at the thin slivers of night
sky visible through the gaps in the tent,
the twinkling of stars just out of reach.
What would become of him after the tour ended?
What horrors awaited him next?
Would he just sit there and take it, or would
he finally do something to bring it all to
a close?
He flexed his muscles quietly, taking notice
of how he had grown over the past few months.
Regular feedings, more than he had gotten
on the street, had bulked him up considerably.
He now stood at over seven feet tall, and
could feel that his strength had doubled,
or even tripled.
The show began as it usually did, with the
crack of the ringmaster's whip.
But suddenly, the man stepped forward and
began a speech he had never made before.
"As you can see, this great beast cowers at
the sound of my whip!
Over the months, I have trained it, domesticated
it until it was aggressive no longer!
Behold, as I set it free!"
And, to Fernand's shock, the ringmaster unlocked
the door to the cage and swung it open.
He took a tentative step out, standing at
his full height for the first time in months
as he stretched his spine straight.
"See how it is tamed!
Go on now, boy!
Smile for your public!
They've been so good to us."
He jabbed Fernand's ribs with his cane, hard
enough to leave a dark purple bruise.
"You heard me, smile!"
The whip cracked again, and the audience began
to boo and jeer, throwing their garbage at
Fernand.
A bag hit his cheek with a slap, and a deep,
dark, rage finally awoke beneath the months
of terror.
"You remember our agreement, do as I say,
or I shall cut off something you’ll miss!"
Before the ringmaster could say another word,
Fernand grabbed him and pulled him into a
bone-crushing embrace.
The man's voice came out in a squeak, "Beast,
what are you doing?"
"That!
Is!
Not!
My name!"
Fernand bellowed, and he opened his mouth
wide, wider than he ever had before, and gobbled
up the ringmaster in three quick bites.
The audience screamed, fleeing from their
seats, but Fernand moved faster than they
did.
He grabbed person after person, starting with
those that had been the cruelest and shouted
the most insulting things, and devoured them
one by one.
When he was full, he ran into the night, into
the forest, and did not stop until he was
free.
He bathed in the river, washing away all that
he had done, and remained there for quite
some time, feeding on passersby when his hunger
got the better of him.
His sense of time grew fuzzy then, and he
could not be sure how long he spent there.
But word of missing townspeople eventually
reached a special organization, one dedicated
to studying those like him, and for the second
time in his life, Fernand was taken into custody
by strangers.
However, these scientists were much kinder
to him, and never called him a beast.
They simply gave him a number, SCP-082.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go and check out “SCP-082 - Fernand
the Cannibal” and “SCP-001 - Can SCP-049
Finally Cure When Day Breaks?”
for more bizarre and disturbing Fernand antics!